>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR SEEN AND
UNSEEN WHERE WE EXPLORE THE
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY AND
FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
RAYMOND THE JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS
WERE ON AGAIN TODAY.
>> LAURA, I WATCHED A LOT OF
THOSE HEARINGS EARLIER AND IF
YOU LIKE DRAMA AND THE VISUALS
ARE NOT THAT APPEALING SO IT'S
CONFUSING TO THE VIEWERS.
THE WITNESSES WERE MOSTLY
VIRTUAL.
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER BILL
STEPIEN LOOKED LIKE HE WAS PHOTO
BOMBING HIS LAWYER DURING A ZOOM
CALL.
THEN POOR FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL BILL BARR SHOWED UP AND
SEEMED TO BE CAPTURED AT A
SECURITY CAM AT A BOARD MEETING.
AND THIS WAS THE BIG REVELATION
OF THE DAY BRACE YOURSELF, THE
COMMITTEE CLAIMED THIS WAS HOT
NEWS.
>> I TOLD THEM THAT THE STUFF
THAT HIS PEOPLE WERE SHOVELING
OUT TO THE PUBLIC WERE BULL
[BLEEP].
THAT THE CLAIMS OF FRAUD WERE
>> HE WAS JUST ON A BOOK TOUR
LAURA IN MARCH WHERE HE TOLD NBC
NEWS THIS.
>> I TOLD THEM THAT ALL THIS
STUFF WAS BULL [BLEEP].
AND ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT WAS WRONG TO
BE SHOVELING IT OUT THE WAY HIS
TEAM WAS.
>> Laura: I MEAN, WHERE WAS THE
NEW NEWS?
I MEAN --
>> LAURA, IT'S ALL RECYCLED.
EVERYTHING.
THE VIDEO'S RECYCLED.
THE TESTIMONY'S RECYCLED AND
BARR ALREADY DID A BOOK ON THIS.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY THESE
NETWORKS ARE HAVING PANELS AND
LIVE COVERAGE LIKE SOMETHING'S
NEW JUST BREAKING.
NOTHING IS NEW HERE.
>> Laura: I LIKE ALL THE --
>> ALL WARMED OVER.
>> Laura: I LIKE ALL THE JUMP
CUT EDITS LIKE SOUND BITE TO
SOUND BITE TO LIVE PERSON, KIND
OF A RUSSIAN ROULETTE OF SOUND
BITES.
I DIDN'T FIND IT CONVINCING.
>> THE UPSHOT IS LAURA IT'S HARD
TO WIN BEST REVIVAL OF AN OLD
POLITICAL STORY WHEN YOUR PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING FROM INFLATION,
FOOD PRICES AND RISING GAS
PRICES.
AND CBS AIRED THE PRIME TIME
HEARING THE FIRST ONE LAST
THURSDAY.
IT DREW 3.24 MILLION VIEWERS.
A WEEK BEFORE A RERUN OF YOUNG
SHELLEDER IN THE SAME TIME SLOT
THREW 3.8 MILLION VIEWERS.
AND YOUR FAVORITE SHOW WAS ON
CBS LAST NIGHT THE TONY AWARDS
DID YOU WATCH?
>> I SADLY MISSED.
>> Laura: UP FROM AN ALL TIME
LOW, LAST YEAR WAS THE SECOND
LOWEST TONY AWARDS EVER WHICH
MAY HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
THE HOSTS.
ARIANA DEVOE WHO APPARENTLY
NEVER HEARD THE ADAGE LET THE
AUDIENCE COME TO YOU.
♪♪
I AM CLOSE TO YOU
OH, SO CLOSE TO YOU
♪♪
I AM TOUCHING YOU
THERE'S NOT A LOT THAT YOU CAN
DO
♪♪
I'M SITTING ON YOU
>> OH, MY LORD.
LAURA, DO YOU SEE WHAT YOU
MISSED.
>> Laura: HE JUST SLIPPED A DISK
IN THAT LAST MOVEMENT THERE, I
THINK.
HE'S GOING TO CALL THE
CHIROPRACTOR.
>> IT WAS A TORTURE US EVENING I
HAVE TO SAY.
AND REMEMBER WHEN BROADWAY DIVA
PATTY CHASTISED A MEMBER OF HER
AUDIENCE A FEW WEEKS BACK?
>> PUT YOUR MASK OVER YOUR NOSE.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE IN THE
THEATER.
THAT'S THE RULE.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO FOLLOW THE
RULE, GET THE [BLEEP] OUT.
>> WELL, LAST NIGHT PATTY LA
UPON WAS THERE MASKLESS IN A
CROWD THOUSANDS IN THE ORCHESTRA
OF RADIO CITY MUSIC HALL.
THERE SHE WAS.
BUT DON'T WORRY, THE WORKERS IN
THE MEZZANINE OF RADIO CITY HAD
TO WEAR THEIR MASKS LAURA.
YOU SEE APPARENTLY COVID STICKS
TO THE LIGHTING GRIDS AT RADIO
CITY SO I GUESS IT'S OKAY FOR
THE FANCY FOLKS ON THE FLOOR.
NO MASKS FOR THEM.
PRETTY GOOD.
>> Laura: I CAN'T BELIEVE,
RAYMOND, THAT THE TONY DIDN'T
GONE TO PHANTOM OF THE COVID
BECAUSE THAT MASK WAS SO, IT WAS
SO IMPRESSIVE.
I MEAN, IT'S CRAZY.
>> BUT IT'S SO HYPOCRITICAL.
THERE IS A MASK MANDATE ON
BROADWAY RIGHT NOW THROUGH
JUNE 30TH.
THE AUDIENCE HAS TO WEAR A MASK.
WHY DON'T THEY HAVE TO WEAR IT?
BAD EXAMPLES HERE.
>> Laura: WELL, WHAT ELSE?
>> WELL, YOU WERE FLIPPING, YOU
WERE TELLING ME YOU WERE
FLIPPING AROUND THE OTHER NIGHT.
>> Laura: OH, YEAH, AND
ACROSS -- YEAH.
I SAW THIS RUE PAUL SHOW AND I
HAVE TO SAY THAT THE MAKEUP ON
SOME OF THE DRAG PERFORMERS I
THOUGHT WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY
CONVINCING.
AND IT'S SO CONVINCING THEY'RE
NOW EVEN IMPERSONATING POLITICAL
FIGURES RAYMOND.
>> PLEASE GIVE A WARM DRAG RACE
WELCOME TO THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI.
>> OH, MY GOD!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> NO, NO, LAURA.
>> Laura: THAT LOOKED LIKE HER.
>> THAT WAS ACTUALLY PELOSI
HERSELF.
>> Laura: WHAT?
>> THAT IS PELOSI.
>> Laura: THAT WAS NOT.
>> IF YOU'RE TRYING TO REACH
VOTERS BEFORE THE MIDTERMS WHERE
ELSE WOULD YOU GO BUT RUE PAUL'S
DRAG RACE.
>> NOW SPEAKER PELOSI, WITH ALL
THE CHALLENGES FACING OUR
NATION, WHAT WORDS OF WISDOM DO
YOU HAVE FOR US?
>> WELL, THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I CAN SAY IS TO
VOTE WITH THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
COMING UP VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE THE MAKE THEIR VOICES AND
THEIR VOTE HEARD.
>> THROW THE WORD MASTER CLASS
AROUND HERE ALL THE TIME BUT
THAT SHADY CLAP YOU DO WAS EPIC.
>> IT WAS COMPLETELY
UNINTENTIONAL.
CAN I GET AN AMEN?
>> Laura: I THINK THEY SHOULD
HAVE DONE THIS RAYMOND.
REMEMBER AFTER TRUMP DID THE
STATE OF THE UNION AND SHE DID
THIS?
REMEMBER THAT.
>> YES.
>> Laura: THAT WAS HER CLASSIC
MOVE.
YEAH.
>> WELL, THIS MAY BE A BACKUP
CAREER FOR NANCY PELOSI, A JUDGE
ON RUE PAUL'S DRAG RACE SHE'LL
HANG UP THE GAVEL.
>> Laura: GOT TO GO.
>> SHE CAN THROW AROUND T